colleagues and people outside of this
place are seriously troubled that arthur
was subjected to a
campaign of appalling cruelty and
murdered after concerns had been raised
with local
services
mr speaker i want to tell you uh and
colleagues across the house and i want
to assure the public
that i am
as determined
as everybody in this house to get to the
truth
and expose what went wrong and take any
action necessary to protect children
to do so
serious questions need to be
asked i want to make clear that police
officers
teachers social workers health workers
and others
go to work each day to try
to make things better
to do their best at what
are very difficult
jobs
those already serving our country's most
vulnerable children
deserve our thanks and i want to be
extremely clear that no safeguarding
professional should be the victim of any
abuse the targeting of individuals is
wrong and helps nobody
but that does not mean we should not
seek to understand what went wrong and
how we can stop it from happening again
the public deserve to know why in this
rare case things went horrifyingly wrong
and what more could be done to prevent
abuse such as this happening
again
in the future
since the horrendous deaths of peter
connolly daniel pelker and sadly others
the government has established stronger
multi-agency working putting a shared
and equal duty on police
councils and health in local areas to
work together to safeguard and promote
the welfare of children
alongside a role for schools
i'm sure members across the house will
recognize that improvements have been
made from previous reviews but the
question now is whether that is enough
in order to look at issues nationally as
well as locally we established the
national child safeguarding practice
review panel in 2017 for cases like
arthur's
that is why given the enormity of this
case the range of agencies
involved and the potential for its
implications to be felt nationally
over the weekend mr speaker i asked
annie hudson chair of the national safe
child safeguarding practice review panel
to work with leaders in solihull to
deliver a single national independent
review of arthur's death to identify
what must be learnt from this terrible
case
this will encompass local government as
well as those working in the police
health and education sectors
officials in my department are already
in close contact with the solihull
safeguarding partnership which is
grateful
for the support offered and agree with
this approach as the best way to deliver
comprehensive national learning
and identify whether there are any gaps
that need to be addressed
annie and her colleagues on the national
panel who come from
the police health and children's
services have dedicated their lives and
decades-long careers to bettering the
lives of the most vulnerable children in
our society and i have every faith that
their review will be robust it will be
vigorous and thorough
i've already assured annie as i assure
you mr speaker now that she will be
given all the support she needs to do
the job properly
this review will focus specifically on
arthur's case and identify where
improvements need to be made but i also
want to make certain we have looked at
how all
the relevant local agencies are working
now including how they are working
together
for that reason i have also asked ofsted
the care quality commission her
majesty's inspection of constabulary and
fire and rescue services and her
master's inspectorate of probation to
lead a joint targeted area inspection i
have asked that each of these
inspectorates be involved because of the
range of local services which had been
involved involved in arthur and his
family's life during the preceding
months
these joint inspections are well
established
but a new ambitious approach will be
used with a sharp focus on the entry
point to the child protection system
across all
agencies
this will mean we can truly look at
where improvements are needed by all the
agencies tasked with protecting children
in this holy hull area so that we can be
assured
that we are doing everything in our
power to protect other children and
prevent such evil crimes
as part of this inspection all the
agencies tasked with protecting children
at risk of abuse and neglect in solely
health will have their effectiveness
considered and instructed on where
improvements must be made both in
solihull as well as where learnings can
be applied to other areas around the
country
these inspectors have met today to plan
this work and the work will begin next
week
i as well as officials in my department
and across government could not be
taking this more seriously and i've been
working this weekend to bring everyone
together to make sure this work can
start
immediately over the coming days we will
publish terms of reference and timelines
for this national review and
the local inspection
ahead of that more widely we are already
investing heavily to help the legions of
dedicated professionals on the front
line deliver the care that we all know
every child deserves
since the spending review in 2019 there
have been year-on-year real terms
increases
for local government as well as the
unprecedented additional six billion
funding provided directly to councils to
support them uh with the immediate and
long-term impact of covet uh spending
pressures including children's social
care yet
we've also known that uh the care system
needed bold and wide-ranging reforms
which is why we have the independent
review of children's social care
happening now
i know that josh mcallister who leads
the review mr speaker will make
recommendations about what a decisive
child protection response needs to look
like given it sits at the core of the
system he is reviewing
and importantly i know that the review
will be looking at how social workers
especially those with the most
experience can spend time with families
and protecting children because we all
know
social workers do their best work with
families not behind a desk
i look forward mr speaker for the
reviews recommendations in due course
because in any complex system it is
important it is imperative in my view to
investigate thoroughly to learn and
improve
the system
my mantra continues to be that sunlight
is the best possible disinfectant
because if we are to improve services
where they need improving we must share
data and evidence
finally mr speaker i'd like to thank the
prosecuting barrister jonas hank and qc
his team and the jury for their service
in this troubling case
as the court heard
arthur's tragic death as a result of the
cruelty of his father and his father's
partner
no government anywhere in the world can
legislate for evil
but we will take action wherever we can
to stop it from happening again because
we must do more
and to do more i'd like to end my
statement with a plea
to everyone in our country anyone who
sees or suspects child abuse can report
their concerns to local children
services or by contacting the government
supported nspcc helpline for adults or
practitioners concerned about a child or
young person
so if you see or suspect child abuse
report it
if you are worried about a child you
know report it if something appears off
or you are seeing something that
troubles you report it
as we uncover what went wrong mr speaker
and what led to arthur's tragic death we
must also strengthen our resolve to make
sure that we prevent these crimes as
much as they can be possibly prevented
we must make sure that those who would
do wicked acts children face justice we
must do absolutely everything in our
power to protect vulnerable young
children from harrowing and evil abuse
and i commend the statement
said the secretary of state
thank you mr speaker and i would like to
thank the secretary of state for
advanced site of his statement to the
house today
mr speaker this has been a truly
horrendous case
my heart goes out to everyone who knew
and loved arthur
and to all of those involved in
investigating and bringing to justice
the depraved and wicked individuals
responsible for his death and i join
with the secretary of state in paying
tribute to front-line workers right
across children's social care who work
so hard to support families day in day
out
i welcome the announcement by the
attorney general's office that the
sentences handed down on friday will be
reviewed under the unduly lenient
sentences scheme
and i welcome the right honourable
gentleman's clear determination to get
to the bottom of what has happened and
his action in ordering a national review
and a joint targeted area inspection
it is right to put in place inquiries as
soon as possible not merely into how
individual agencies acted but how they
acted together
and it's vital that whatever lessons can
be learned from what was happened and
what didn't happen in solihull are acted
on as soon as possible
searching questions must be asked about
the way in which services operated
locally
but questions must also be asked
nationally
questions about how the services that
should be keeping children safe are
overseen
and why tragically cases like this keep
happening
now i know the secretary of state takes
these issues just as seriously as i do
and i very much hope that he will be
reviewing urgently
the way in which services are inspected
are challenged and are improved
and i asked the secretary of state who i
know who hasn't been in his post for too
long
to ensure that his own department gets
its house in order
in 2016 the department committed to a
target that by 2020 all vulnerable
children no matter where they live
receive the same high quality of care
and support and the best outcome for
every child is at the heart of every
decision made
the then permanent secretary told the
public accounts committee that this
target was delayed to 2022 because the
department did not have a detailed plan
in place to deliver that target
the public accounts committee found that
the department had made only limited
progress in improving the quality of
children's social care services
and in 2019 the permanent secretary
accepted that having nearly 60
of local authorities rated lower than
good by ofsted for children's social
care was terrible
indeed he told the public accounts
committee
i'm not able to sit in front of you and
see that there will be no councils
failing their ofsted inspections in
clearly there will be
some schools fail some hospitals fail
and some councils fail
mr speaker failure should never be an
acceptable outcome for any public
service and that is especially true when
it comes to protecting children
for too long this government has
tolerated failing children services and
a failure to protect children
vulnerable children are being failed and
that cannot go on
the secretary of state must now set out
how he plans to tackle that culture that
failing services are acceptable in our
country acceptable for our children in
his own department just as much as in
sully hull
that is the challenge he faces
and that is the standard by which he
will be judged
one final point mr speaker
we have heard a lot in recent days about
the unimaginable suffering this little
boy endured at the hands of two evil
individuals who brought an end to his
short life
but i hope that we can remember also how
in better days arthur lived his short
life
i hope that while we do not hesitate to
learn from these tragic events
we also as far as we can
remember arthur for who he was not what
others did to him or for how he was let
down
i hope that when we hear his name we
think first of a gentle caring happy
child
the little boy who was remembered so
movingly by so many across our country
this weekend
the little boy with the beaming smile
who should still be here with us today
thank you mr speaker so
i'm grateful for the honourable lady's
words and especially her um final
uh few sentences uh in the way we should
remember arthur and remember that there
are uh family members who are grieving
uh for arthur
uh today i think
she makes a powerful point about making
sure we continue on the path to
improvements i spent
uh a a good amount of time as a children
families minister in the department of
education
and i think the team
have really focused on those
improvements in children's social care
um she spoke about um
a long way to go and i think
i would recognize that there are
challenges but i think it's also worth
praising the team uh both in the
department but also in local government
up and down the country where uh
we
not a long time ago only had about 37
of local authorities uh having a good
offset inspection um i think uh the one
thing i would correct you on i don't
think it's so binary it's parts and
failed because actually it's very much
about
areas of of improvements in children's
social uh care but that 37 now has risen
to 50 of uh local authorities that have
got a good um inspection and of course
we can have to continue on that path and
keep going uh further but i'm very
pleased to hear uh supporting the course
of action you've taken today
but now comes the chair of the select
committee robert holden thank you mr
speaker i i strongly endorse
what the secretary of state um has set
out and with the review and also
um welcome the uh particularly
entrepreneurs of the shadow of the
shadow secretary which was very moving
um i just um as i understand it
this tragic this tragedy happened and
the arthur was not in school and had
been kept at home
by um his uh father
um my right old friend will know that um
putting aside the
200 000 children who the
school system know about who are being
sent home through kobe there are another
hundred thousand what i call the ghost
children who are lost to the system who
haven't uh returned to school for the
most
time who are subject to
potentially to safeguarding hazards
county line gangs online harms and of
course awful domestic abuse
so i ask my right on friend to ensure
that we're not in this house again
discussing
these kind of issues or witnessing a
further tragedy
that we have just heard about
that he proactively
makes a real effort to work with the
local authorities to work with the
schools and the regional commissioners
to make sure
that those hundred thousand children who
are mostly not in school are returned to
school and are being watched by uh those
uh of those uh
authorities when they that they need to
be watched we have to get these children
back into school otherwise we'll face i
i hope not but we may face further
tragedies along the way yeah
i'm grateful uh for
my uh honourable friend and chairman of
the education select committee i think
uh he is absolutely right to raise this
issue it is a concerning issue as a
focus for my department i am working
closely with other departments and
agencies uh to work uh through this he
will know that we launched see here
respond program to aim supporting
vulnerable children young people whose
usual support networks were impacted by
the pandemic and national
restrictions uh that the uh tragedy for
arthur is he wasn't ever off the school
uh register but nevertheless the point
the chairman of the education the select
committee makes is a powerful and open
to snp spokesperson carol monahan thank
you mr speaker and i thank the secretary
of state for advanced site obvious
statement and it's unusual that we're
here in this house with so much
cross-party agreement on an issue but
the secretary of state spoke from the
heart and with a real um genuine desire
for change and i hope we can be
supportive of that and i also want to
join him in commending those who brought
arthur's killers to justice and i wish
to offer both my condolences and the
condolences of snp members
to um arthur's family and loved ones
this tragic death has affected us all
and the
the footage of the little boy saying no
one loves me will remain with many of us
i think parents
hugged their own children a lot harder
when they heard that and were shocked
for two reasons firstly that these
people exist and were put in charge of
such an innocent little soul
and secondly the opportunities were
missed
that would have prevented this tragedy
the government review is important
but if failings are found to be due to
resourcing
will the secretary of state commit to
properly and directly funding child
protection services it's not enough that
they're coming through councils if it
needs direct government funding will he
do that
and he talked about agencies working
together how is he going to monitor how
well this actually happens
there has to be cross-party working in
this so can the secretary of state
assure us today that he will genuinely
listen to cross-party um recommendations
and suggestions and how this can be
improved none of us want to have another
arthur bbp or victoria clintbay so um
let's make sure that we can do the best
of politics in this and make sure no
other vulnerable children are harmed
i'm grateful for the honourable lady and
for the way she is um uh so generously
offering um the support on a cross-party
basis and i hope she will remember that
um
when i was the vaccine deployment
minister i always
worked on a
cross-party
way of of of
cooperating and coordinating and
i hope what we can do through the
mcallister review josh mcallister
reviews make sure we reach uh out across
this house uh and share uh that but also
the the two reviews that uh are
specifically to um uh this tragic uh
death of uh
uh young arthur
julian knight
may i thank my honorable friend for his
statement also his engagement over the
last 52 hours
no one loves me
no one is going to feed me
those the words that broke the hearts of
my town
and it seems our country as well
a young lad who never had a chance
he experienced unimaginable brutality in
his short life
will my right humble friend confirm that
no stone will remain unturned no
difficult question
remain unasked
this investigation will proceed without
fear nor favor and at the end of it
we'll know clearly and publicly
who failed after and how he was failed
in addition more itemable friend ensure
the investigation
focuses on the clear breakdown in
partnerships between the likes of social
services the police and educators
why on earth weren't they talking to
each other
at the very least we owe it to arthur
that every lesson from this horrific
tragedy is learned and no towel as it's
heartbroken like solihulls out
secretary of state
i'm grateful uh for
my uh honorable friends words and
the words of arthur that i know have
torn the heart of the nation
um i assure him that
the
both reviews will be able to go wherever
they need to
um
i hope
that he agrees with me that
transparency
is the best disinfectant uh in this case
and i just want to
a place on record mr speaker and commend
him uh for making himself available uh
at all times um
when we needed
to
make contact and discuss with him and
his office uh what we were planning to
announce in the house thank you very
much
emma laurel buck thank you very much mr
speaker
little arthur's murder has really
affected those of us who have direct
experience of working closely with
abused children
it's a matter of record that when the
secretary of state was children's
minister and i was his shadow i
repeatedly warned him that pursuing this
government's agenda of cuts
increasing bureaucracy deregulation and
privatization of child protection would
cost a child's life
like his predecessors he ignored me
however
i know that the min that the secretary
of state is a genuinely caring man and i
certainly don't have all the answers
here
but will he please now meet with me so
we can at last work together to make
sure that no other precious little life
is so brutally taken again
secretary of state thank you madam
deputy speaker and i uh first of all be
delighted to meet with the honourable
lady i think her characterization is
slightly unfair in the sense that
not only do we work towards improving
the system and the team both in the
department and on the front line did
tremendous work of course we
worked on a step up into social care
front line
which delivered thousands of of uh new
entrants into the social care system i
think since 2017 we've seen an uplift of
10
of the social care workforce uh which i
hope she will agree is to be commended
but i'm very happy to also meet with her
because i know she cares passionately
about this subject
security
thank you madam mr speaker and i stand
with great sadness today my constituents
in meridian who are served by solid hill
council have been devastated by the
death of arthur my thoughts go out to
those who love them and i pay tribute to
that young boy with that beautiful smile
i welcome the announcements of the
inspections and the reviews today i
don't think any member of parliament
ever wants to be standing here
addressing circumstances such as this
and i completely also agree in the uh
attorney general's review of the
sentencing and i have to admit many
times over the last few days i've
thought they should lock them up and
throw away the key
unfortunately we have been here before
madam deputy speaker and what
reassurances can my right to my friend
give to my constituents
that this inquiry inquiry will be a
meaningful one that will and bring
meaningful change that will protect
children like arthur in the future
secretary of state i'm grateful for uh
i'm defense uh important question and i
would reassure him that both reviews
will be thorough
will be
shared
with the house but also will feed into
josh mcallister's overall
review of children's social care and i
have to say uh uh that uh you know 29
years a minimum
for
uh uh the murder of of arthur in 21
years uh for his father as well uh is um
what the court could deliver but i know
that the attorney general uh has had a
request um uh to look again at the
leniency of that of that uh sentence
diane abbott
the statue of state said earlier that he
will do
anything it takes to protect children
so can the secretary of state assure the
house that if it transpires
that one of the main issues behind the
horrific
and cruel death of this child was not
enough social workers
too much pressure on existing social
workers that he will make the case to
his colleagues in government to make the
right level of resources available very
well
secretary of state i'm grateful uh to my
honourable uh the honourable members uh
question and i want to thank
the 34 000 uh social workers who are
out today and every day uh protecting uh
young people and of course uh we
continue to
look to bring more into the profession i
mentioned earlier a 10 percent rise in
2017
but whatever the uh uh reviews and of
course
the mcallister review uh recommends uh
it is exactly the thing that we will
look to implement
tim norton
can i refer to my uh
entry in the register
i'm sure the secret states shares my
sense of deja vu this tragic case
revealed familiar failings raised 12
years ago by lord laming in his report
into the baby p and how we have need to
have better joint working 11 years ago
when we started publishing serious case
reviews so we could all learn from them
and 10 years ago when i launched the
munro review crucially not as a
knee-jerk reaction to a recent tragedy
to free up social workers from the
bureaucracy that was keeping them from
eyeballing and face to face time with
those vulnerable families so whilst
welcoming
definitely welcoming the government's
determination to respond urgently with a
review can i suggest that first
he reviews why the findings of previous
reviews have not been acted on or why
the system has not allowed the necessary
changes to happen here
secretary of state i'm grateful uh to my
honorable friend's uh question and he um
has what i would describe as
institutional memory
of
the
children's social care system and of
course uh his work as uh children and
families minister and department is has
uh uh remained invaluable uh he's right
to challenge us on making sure that um
what we intend to implement uh from
those reviews including the monterey
review um which um the department
accepted almost i think the majority
of the uh recommendations uh what
happens then operationally on the ground
uh to reflect that and i think that's
that that is equally important it's why
uh the mcallister review is is so
important
so that actually it deals with the
operational challenges so we can turn
some of this stuff into reality on the
ground
stephen k
thank you uh
deputy speaker can i thank the secretary
of state for the the tone of his
statement and uh as someone who once did
this work i'm very worth uh
to start picking on individuals i do
understand but i do want to say to him
that leadership in this kind of work is
very important and i hope that some
aspect of the inquiry will look at
senior management appointments and that
the apparent senior managerial
merry-go-round that can allow someone to
leave a failing department and assume an
almost identical post in a neighboring
authority
secretary of state i'm grateful uh for
my friends uh important question i think
the um reviews will
look at all aspects of uh
the failures
um
in
this tragic case um it's worth just
reminding the house that it is uh
directors of children's uh uh services
work also with regulations with chief
execs and of course lead members and i
think it's
you know in my time it's still a family
minister i remember it's that
combination of leadership that really
does deliver
the right outcomes that we want to see
but the review will look at that as well
dr caroline johnson
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
refer members to my register of interest
because i'm a children's doctor um
arthur's case has shocked and saddened
all of us
but as members have already said we have
been here before with some of that cases
and in my career i have seen and looked
after far too many children who've been
injured and hurt by those who are
supposed to love them and care for them
the most
i'm really welcoming the ministers and
social states review and i hope it will
successfully reduce the number of cases
but i wanted to focus my question on
justice in particular because i have
seen cases where we've identified
problems but they've been let down
either because the cps have accepted
lesser pleas to avoid court cases
because in one case i remember the
barrister didn't know the name of the
children he'd come to represent local
care proceedings west sentences have
passed which have been hideously too low
for the severity of the heinous crimes
that have been committed so i asked
secretary state to confirm when he's
doing his review will he be working with
the ministry of justice in these cases
too
secretary of state i can certainly
confirm that we will be working with uh
uh ministers across government on this
i'm ira wilson
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
can i thank the secretary of state for
his statement and the sentiments
expressed within it and the actions that
he's taking i like everybody else have
found the details of this case harrowing
not least because arthur was the same
mate as my daughter and it's just
unbelievable and my thoughts are with
all those who knew and loved him um
given that we know that among the social
worker uh workforce there are there's a
high turnover rate there's about seven
and a half percent vacancy rate at the
moment and we know that about a quarter
of that workforce is due for retirement
in the next 10 years could i ask that
whether it's in through this review or
the mcallister review that the secretary
of state will commit to looking at
recruitment retention and training of
social workers and also given their
workload has gone up whilst there's been
some 2.2 billion pounds of cuts to uh
social services over the last decade
will he commit that
to whatever resources it takes because
we cannot put a price on a child's life
secretary of state i'm grateful for uh
the on remembers uh uh question i think
um
she's absolutely right that we need to
make sure that we continue to retain
uh the uh more experienced uh social
worker leadership um and i think it's
something that
the mcallister review
i hope will make some operational
recommendations on that uh of course we
have had two very successful schemes
with frontline
and step up into social care which
resulted in uh you know thousands of uh
people coming into the social care
profession um and the the number of
social workers has gone up by 10 since
2017
but where she is absolutely right
we have far too many if you look at the
system overall agency workers which i
think is a
point where you want um that experience
and that leadership to be
full-time in a local authority system
rather than working on an agency basis
lucia
thank you very much dr speaker and i
would like to thank secretary of state
for his statement after his turn
throughout this session
i know when he was children's minister
that he was passionate about child
safeguarding and i know that
children are in safe hands with him at
the helm and i'm grateful for that this
horrific case shows that
fundamental reform of children's social
care is now long overdue lessons learned
and case reviews are just not enough
um does the minister agree that the
problems with children's social care are
systemic and that the challenges faced
are not just about funding and will he
also agree that scapegoating individuals
particularly inexperienced social
workers
will not improve the care of these most
vulnerable children
secretary of state i'm grateful for for
my uh honourable friends she's
absolutely right uh to say that
we have to make sure uh we deliver
better outcomes and the way
we recognize that which is why we made
it a manifesto pledge that we would have
the uh review the mcallister review
which uh will uh
i'm confident uh deliver uh
recommendations uh that i hope we can uh
be ambitious and uh deliver rapidly uh
where she's
also uh right is to say that um
we we can't just uh continue to have uh
review after review we have to learn
from those and operationally implement
the recommendations why because uh and
this is i'm passionate about this in any
complex system you have to have a
thorough investigation because that's
how you improve complex systems um and
make them uh
fail safe for those they're protected
mary sheaman
madam deputy speaker
i remember that when i was the chair of
the select committee for 10 years the
education site committee we had some
awful cases uh tragic tragic cases like
this
and my heart goes out to i think
laughter and you know anyone who knew
him
but
i like the tone of the secretary of
state's opening remarks uh when baby
peter baby p
investigation went on there was a human
cry
from the popular media and some
politicians joined it and i still have a
guilty conscience of the way if sharon
shoesmith was handed out of office and
never ever no one ever apologized for
what happened to that woman
uh can i just
two quick things
he will know that good children services
and good multi-agency working is
expensive and we need the resources in
local government to actually deliver and
finally
one of the most worrying things when i
was chair of the state committee
is this reluctance to
square up the fact we should know where
every child in our country is
home schooling has put a big question
mark over knowing what is happening
children in the home environment does he
share my concern and could we have a
conversation about it at a later date
secretary of state i'm grateful for uh
my honourable friend
and his very important uh uh question
just to unpack a little bit of it i
think um
he is uh right to say that uh we need to
make sure we know where every child is
there are some
excellent
examples of home schooling with parents
who really do a great job
but that's not always the case
i know that he cares passionately about
the work of children's social
services and i hope
that
he will continue
uh to care for this when he leaves this
place
as he has announced he's doing he will
be
sorely missed i think and his input uh
will be missed but um his point around
local councils obviously in this year
and next year's budget they've got a
spending power of about 51.3 billion uh
core spending power for their services
they've had a real-time increase um uh
in terms of what they can do with the
six billion obviously to cope with
covert as well
but nevertheless i think it's important
that we
don't scapegoat anyone and he's
absolutely right we've got to make sure
that we allow the uh
both the panel and the review to take
their course and report back to this
house bob blackman yes thank you madam
deputy speaker i go back a little longer
than other people and refer to the
jasmine beckford case as well as the
victoria columbia case the baby peter
case and now that of arthur the one
common theme throughout this whole
terrible series of events
is that the opportunities to take a
child to safety were missed
so will my right old friend make sure
that the message goes out to front line
children social workers if they have a
suspicion
a suspicion of a child being abused it
will be thoroughly investigated and if
necessary that child will be removed to
a place of safety
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
honourable friends uh question and he is
right to remind us of the blackfoot
obviously columbia uh uh and tragically
now arthur uh case um
i think um
social workers uh are
doing a tremendous job and i think it's
important that um that
multi-agency um work that
for whatever reason we'll find out
through
uh
these two uh reviews missed
uh uh arthur in this case and didn't uh
take him away or obviously has you know
evil manipulative father and uh
the partner but nevertheless uh we have
to make sure that uh if there is any
evidence any inkling any iota of harm to
each other the child is taken away
immediately
karen mccarthy
thank you madam deputy speaker
300 000 children a year are affected by
parental imprisonment and as i
understand it after was one of them so
what this case highlights is the lack of
a statutory mechanism to identify and
support such children the moment that he
was put in i won't say his father's care
but in his father's charge um there
should have been that identification and
support there i am due to meet the the
minister to discuss this on monday but
can i just urge the secretary of state
that this needs flagging up within this
review
secretary of state the honourable lady
that raises an important point i know uh
for my time as children and families
minister she has been uh campaigning um
on this issue and i know she's meeting
the minister for children and families
on monday but i will certainly take a
look very closely at what she says and
feedback to the panel as well
kelly tolhurst
thank you madam deputy speaker um i must
declare my sister is a social worker and
no one can understand how beautiful
little arthur died at the hands of the
people that were charged of caring for
him
and i have great respect for my
honourable friend and i know that he
will
absolutely be determined in his uh
passion to get to exactly why this
happened and the learnings that we can
take forward but does my right
honourable friend agree with me that it
is now finally time
to really look and deal with the case
the case load that these social workers
have to deal with
with some of them excessive case loads
very complicate complex cases can we
finally give social workers
the confidence the safety and the time
to be able to do the job that they love
and get up every morning to
keep children safe
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
honourable friends incredibly important
question she will
i hope remember when i was children
family minister that i um was the
champion of uh social workers and i will
continue uh to be the champion for
social workers as secretary of state uh
and i will
i'm very confident that the mcallister
review hence why it was such a priority
uh certainly uh for us for it to be in
our manifesto it's so important that we
now get this right and caseload is very
much
part of that as she quite rightly
identifies
paul turner thank you madam deputy
speaker the most important job the state
must have
is to protect
vulnerable
children
but social care is facing a mounting
crisis
now i know the secretary of state and i
trust entirely
that he'll do everything in his power to
get to the bottom
of what led to this terrible tragedy but
i just wonder
would he please at least that knowledge
that 60
cuts to local authorities in the past
decade is potentially having a dramatic
impact on these services
i'm grateful for the honourable
gentleman i
i
will always go where the
evidence leads the reason
uh we've asked josh mcallister to
conduct this review
prior to this tragic murder of this
innocent young boy
is because we know we want to make sure
we deliver a system that is fit for
purpose uh
we made more funding available but it it
depends what the review will come back
and i would certainly
be at this dispatch box and go through
that
with colleagues here to make sure we get
this right
sam hall
indeed
deputy speaker and like many can i just
say what a belief it is that my right
hong kong friend is at the hell uh on
this issue because this has been a
bone chilling case
he was right in his statement when he
said that no government anywhere in the
world can legislate for evil and we have
seen evil in this case
and we also know that hard-working
professionals can't be everywhere all of
the time
quite rightly the campaign for violence
against women and girls
has a high national profile
and a command of respect of ministers
across government
can i urge my right honourable friend to
begin such a crusade
to combat uh to combat uh neglect and
violence against children
and whereas others have noted the
precautionary principle
the taking away of a child if there's a
scintilla
of doubt
is at the forefront of people's minds
where the resources are available and
the law stands for square behind them
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
uh honourable friends um question and
suggestion and i would certainly like to
take that away and also work on a
cross-party basis to make it um
just culturally unacceptable
for children to be neglected or
to be harmed or abused in any way
thank you madam deputy speaker i'd also
like to thank secretary state for his
statement and his commitment
to get to the bottom of this
i um associate myself to all the remarks
from members across this house and like
many members i've got two young children
and i had my six-year-old and
four-year-old a little bit tighter this
weekend
in just so much sadness
one area which i've highlighted in this
house before
is the fact that we've seen shortcomings
within the safeguarding system and they
do need to be addressed but i'd also
like to draw the house's attention to
young girls and young children who are
in vulnerable situations and in some
cases aren't known to the authorities
i've highlighted the problem with
hidden gang associated girls
many of whom are never picked up so i'd
like to ask the secretary of state if
you would ensure that all children who
are at risk of violence and exploitation
are identified and properly cared for
secretary of state i'm grateful for the
honourable lady and her very moving
words about her own
children i think
um i felt exactly the same way um this
this weekend about my nine-year-old
daughter um she highlights a very
important point which i think the
mcallister review is very much about
making sure that we have a system that
is decisive
um when it comes to protection of of
children
little truck
thank you madam deputy speaker um can i
thank my right honourable friend for his
statement and can i ask him to be
mindful as i know he will be of learning
the lessons from other tragic cases
particularly baby p
where we saw a massive increase in
referrals and also a massive increase in
the number of children take away from um
the
care that they were currently in
i think we need an increase in resources
for social workers in the near term to
handle that increase in referrals and i
do think there is a balance that needs
to be struck between taking children
away from their parents or the home that
they're in and making sure that they're
safe and that he is sending out that
message to social workers
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
honourable friends very important uh
question i think she's absolutely right
um around how uh social workers and i've
seen them uh do this brilliantly in
terms of identifying support networks uh
for children of course if there is a
scintilla of doubt in terms of any harm
being caused to a child they absolutely
should uh take away but she also makes a
very important point that um
in
learning from
previous cases the additional
work uh that will be now placed on the
social work front line is something that
we are very cognizant of and i know the
minister for children families is
looking at how we can continue to
support the front line
john mcdonnell
unfortunately we're too good at setting
up reviews and blaming others
this house needs to take some
responsibility
in march 2018 the honourable member for
reddish denton reddish published with me
a report based upon consultation
children's charities local government
and social work professionals that said
after two billion pounds worth of cuts
children were at risk and could not be
protected we put four proposals in the
budget that year and in the following
year and in the following year
40 percent cut in early interventions on
children
we all get emotional about this i was 15
years on child care and dealt with
children who have been abused i never
ever want to see it again
i don't doubt the sincerity of this
minister we've worked with him he's done
a good job where he's been in most cases
so this is a message through him to the
chancellor we need an emergency funding
package for children's services now we
can't wait months for another review the
social workers are overworked and
actually underpaid and disrespected we
need them properly funded and supported
thank you mr speaker i would
respectfully say that i don't think
anybody in this house um would ever
disrespect uh the social work workforce
or any uh social worker i i also think
that um actually having evidence-based
strategy is important which is why the
mcallister review is is so important uh
to this uh it's worth remembering that
the course spending of local government
uh has increased on an average of three
percent in real terms each year of the
next uh spending review period um so
more money is going into local
government but depending on what what
the mikasa review does uh deliver i
would certainly be the the first to make
uh the the argument for uh properly
resourcing children's social care david
simmons
well thank you madam debut speaker mark
like others may i thank the secretary of
state for the tone of the statement
today
um does my rightful friend agree with me
that the 1989 children act
which provides the main legislative and
operational underpinning of children's
social care
is perhaps in need of updating does he
have a view about how that might happen
and as you further agree with me picking
up the point made today by the
honourable member for solihull that it
is perhaps a weakness in our local
safeguarding partnership model that
schools and education are not a
statutory safeguarding partner
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
honourable friend i know he has deep
experience uh in this area
i think he's quite right uh manchester
speaker that
we do need to carefully consider all
possible routes uh to help ensure that
uh children's social care has the powers
that they need to
protect vulnerable children like arthur
i think um
it's important that we wait for uh both
of the reviews uh before we look at
specific legends of improvements that we
may take we obviously need to make sure
that the national panel report and
findings of the joint target area
inspection come back and of course we
have the independent review that the
mutasa reviews conducted i will not rule
out
legislative changes if we need to make
them
andrew going thank you and can i also
thank the secretary of state for the
tone of this statement but he keeps
mentioning increases in local government
core funding in the
spending review period but as my right
honourable friend for hazen harlington
has just said this does not outstrip a
decade of damage which has left a
perfect storm for children's services
alongside increasing demand and
ballooning caseloads for social workers
there are massive pressures in the
system so i ask him sincerely to go to
the chancellor to make the case for
children's services to get that
additional resource that is so
desperately needed so that no vulnerable
child is failed in the way that little
arthur has been
secretary of state i'm grateful for the
honourable members uh question i think
um
the
funding is one important part of this um
equation absolutely but i think equally
important is that we make sure um we
look at what went wrong um and why and
then how we're going to operationally
fix that and when you speak to the likes
of uh martinery who i was speaking to
over the weekend he will say uh to this
house that it's not
only uh funding it's actually making
sure we
have the operational competence uh to
support children's social
care and the front line in doing their
job because where they need to be the
best place for social workers they tell
me all the time is to be with families
working with families rather than on the
bureaucracy that sits behind
nikki aiken thank you speaker
i have never met a social worker who
does not go to work every day to make a
difference to the people they serve
and
i do fear that we don't in this nation
always hold social workers in the high
regard that we do with teachers police
officers nurses doctors and i think that
needs to change
as a former cabinet member for
children's services i believe
fully that it is about local
accountability
and that local councillors whether it's
the lead member whether it's the leader
of the council has a role to play
in keeping children safe it's not just
about the dcs's and the social workers
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that it's probably about time
that the department of education works
with the local government association
and other organizations within local
government to ensure that cabinet
members and council leaders really
appreciate the role they have to play
in keeping our children safe
secretary of state
i thank the honorable uh my honourable
friends for her excellent question and i
touched on
uh on it a little bit early i think
she's absolutely right to say where i
have seen really good evidence of high
performing children's services is when
the chief executive the lead member are
working and supporting the director of
clinical services and the front line and
really understand how the system is
working in their locality so
i can
certainly reassure her that both myself
and the minister for children and
families will leave no stone unturned in
the work that we do with local
government on this
kat smith
thank you uh madame dr speaker i agree
with the secretary of state that our
experienced social workers need to spend
more time working with families and not
stuck behind a desk doing paperwork but
it is actually a direct consequence of
more than a decade of cuts to local
government that has led to experienced
social workers leaving the profession
because of feeling overburdened and
rising caseloads and also
directly because of those cuts that they
are actually having to do more paperwork
and you can see this pattern emerging
through 10 years of research by the
british association of social workers so
can i invite the secretary of state to
make time for a meeting of myself as an
officer of the appg on social work and
the british association of social
workers to discuss the things that we
can do to actually encourage retention
and obviously recruitment of social
workers so we can actually have those
experienced social workers working
directly with families
secretary of state i'm grateful for the
honourable ladies question um i would
certainly make time as will uh the
minister for children and families i
think she raises a really important
point and i remember when i
held the portfolio
we had the what works in children's
social care which is a a sort of
an evidence-led approach to do this and
i'm very happy uh to uh look at the
evidence that that she and the appg can
provide as well as uh bringing the team
that that is leading on the what works
in children's social care
kieran mellon thank you madam deputy
speaker like many others i found myself
in tears at the weekend thinking about
what happened to poor little arthur and
i welcome the fact that sentences
potentially going to be reviewed but i
think we shouldn't get overly optimistic
at best we might see increasing a few
years because actually sentencing
practice in this country is woefully
sure of what most people think of as
justice in cases like this every person
i've spoken to everyone that's contacted
me wants to see both of these despicable
individuals locked up for the rest of
their lives and i hugely welcome the
changes we're making on premeditated
child murder to make it so that you
should expect a whole life tariff but
does it
remember agree with me that any adult
that murders a child should expect to
spend the rest of their life in prison
regardless of whether or not i was
pre-meditated
i'm grateful to uh my own friend's
question i know he feels very strongly
about the issue and he and i have
discussed this
very recently
he quite rightly reminds the house that
last week
the government announced that we are
currently amending the police crime and
sentencing and courts bill to include
tony's law which will increase the
maximum penalty for child cruelty
causing or allowing serious physical
harm from 10 to 14 years and the maximum
penalty for causing or allowing the
death of a child from 14 years to life
imprisonment
george howard
thank you madam
deputy speaker can i
congratulate the secretary of state
on the thoughtful but determined way
he's approached this tragic situation
could i
suggest also he's mentioned
the need for multi-agency working and
i'm sure he's right about that
but could i suggest also that as part of
the review
they look at the possibility of placing
a duty on those agencies to share
information
because that seems to have been a
problem in this case and also it to
establishing a mechanism
whereby such information
as has been received
is properly assessed to see what further
steps should be taken in those cases and
of course as others have said we do need
the resources to be put in to make a
system like that work
secretary today i'm grateful for the
honor members question he raises a
really important issue although there is
that
duty
to work together and of course to share
information one of the things i want the
investigation to look at is how well is
that working how can we improve it
because clearly in this case
it has
not worked which is why we've lost
poor arthur
jane hunt thank you very much madame
deputy speaker if it takes a village to
raise a child let's not make it the case
that a whole village has to raise the
issue before concerns are addressed
i wonder if the uh writer my right
honourable friend would look in the case
of the review about outcomes rather than
following rules
let's let's um allow uh these
multi-agent agency groups to be bold to
make bold decisions and to have the
confidence that we will support them
secretary of state i'm grateful for my
honourable friends of course she raises
a really really fundamental issues is
that the system needs to have that
confidence
and ability to safeguard and protect and
of course
build on
relationships that child may have with
other members of the family kinship care
if necessary or otherwise
that comes through really high quality
leadership and that's why that is so
much been the focus of uh my work at the
time and
as children families minister but i know
my uh
honourable friend the minister now
continues that work too but the review
she's right should look at that too
davey
thank you madam deputy speaker i have 15
years of experience in children's social
care as a social worker and i thank the
shadow minister for saying that
uh secretary of state for saying that um
he will be a champion for uh social
workers uh the death of arthur is
absolutely tragic and i thank him also
for his statement however it is not a
new phenomenon that social workers are
overworked and they spend most of their
time doing bureaucratic work uh the
review to do with monroe
uh louise
casey and also uh josh mcallister has
also stated that social workers spend
far too much time during the bureaucracy
of their work instead of being with
families uh social workers are
overworked what interim measures will
the uh secretary put in place now and
what are the time scales of when is his
review will be uh completed
i'm grateful uh for the honolulu i want
to thank her for her 15 years of service
as a social worker she's absolutely
right
first quarter next year there will be a
reduction in that uh bureaucracy that's
coming uh down the line even before
the uh review but she's also right uh to
say that actually uh there is uh too
much bureaucracy i'll never forget going
out
with a brilliant social worker in in
bryson who is a phenomenon i mean doing
incredible work with with the most
vulnerable young people and she said to
me privacy i know i shouldn't be saying
this to you because you're the minister
but i'm not good at you know using some
of these uh technologies or bureaucracy
which is why i'm finding it so difficult
so i'm going to retire and that's the
sort of thing that i think the
mcallister review needs to look at very
thoroughly
mark jenkins thank you madam deputy
speaker and can i thank my honourable
friend for his statement and for his
commitment to leave no stone unturned in
this tragic case
in my constituency workington
teachers often find themselves at the
front line of social work and i'll just
put on record that i am the husband of a
teaching assistant some of our
secondaries are pilots for social
workers in schools but we know that
early intervention is key so will he
look at potentially rolling out the
social workers and schools project to
primaries across cumbria as well
secretary of state
i'm grateful for my uh honourable
friends uh question i would certainly
take a good look at
that particular pilot in my time again
as uh children families minister i saw
similar projects
that did tremendous work uh in schools
with the most vulnerable children and
their families
nick whitley thank you madam destiny
speaker i'd also like to thank the
secretary of state for this throne this
afternoon
the tragic death of arthur lavender
hughes has shocked and grieved our
nation and served as a painful
reminder that nearly enough has been
done to protect vulnerable children
since the death of baby pay over a
decade ago
lord layman who shared the inquiry into
the into the death of extraordinary
climate has won that centuries of
austerity measures have seriously
undermined the ability of social
services to protect young people most at
risk or see of serious harm does the
secretary of state agree that urgently
storing funding lost since 2010 is
essential if we are to stop any child
from suffering as arthur so tragically
dead
secretary of state
i'm grateful uh for my uh honorable
friends uh question i think it's
important that we do recognize that the
new uh funding that's going into liberal
government uh over the spending period
4.8 billion uh in total
but the mcallister review will i hope
also give us an opportunity to look at
how we operationally make best use of uh
uh funding but also understand where
that bureaucracy lies to free up the
front line to make it an attractive
profession of course to
be part of as well
so all that work
will will continue at pace once we have
the review back
last question matt rodden thank you
madam deputy speaker i i would like to
offer my deepest condolences to little
arthas family and friends this has been
a truly dreadful case his colleagues
across the house have said today
i thank the secretary of state for his
tone and his commitment on this
important issue
i would like to hear more from him about
his willingness to leave no stone
unturned to do whatever it takes in this
case
to explore how we can support these
vital public sector workers who need so
much help and encouragement for this
difficult time will he look both at the
pay for social workers the numbers of
social workers the integration of
different agencies and indeed leave no
stone unturned including looking at his
own department
it's okay today i'm grateful for uh the
members uh question and um
again thank uh all colleagues uh for the
um uh input and the tone of this
important uh debate that we've had uh
today um the mcallister review is
looking uh at exactly how we make sure
we deliver the best outcome and the
support that we offer uh the front line
i think um
sadly in many ways i just want to end by
really recognizing this mandatory
speaker is
the incredible work that social workers
do day in day out
uh
week in week out year and year out
doesn't get much recognition
uh
the real tragedy it only
reaches this dispatch box when there is
a tragedy uh like um uh daniel pelker or
now young
arthur
i just want to place on record that
social workers are not
on their own they're not forgotten they
will always be supported i hope
that
both
the review that i've announced today but
also the mcallister review will mean we
could continue
in our support for the front line to
make sure we get the best outcomes
possible for the most vulnerable
children and families in our country
well i thank the
secretary of state
for his statement and
is the point of order relevant to the
statement that's just taken place
okay point of order diana
the
secretary of state in response to my
question about resources
implied certainly that he would be
willing to support any resources about
finance that the mcallister review made
but the secretary of state would have
known perfectly well
that his department the department for
education
have signed a contract with mcallister
which says he cannot assume additional
government funding that any
recommendations about funding must be
matched by savings elsewhere in
government over a period of time and
that any recommendations
must be affordable to government how can
the secretary of state
assure the house that he is willing to
support
recommendations for extra money when the
contractor department has signed would
seem to apply any such recommendations
would not be acceptable
uh well i uh thank the right honourable
lady for that point of order it is not
actually a point of order for the chair
but obviously
uh it has enabled her to put on
record and to seek any clarification
on detail that the secretary of state
replied to her
may wish to
give further information on i'm sure the
secretary of state has heard what she
said um and i know
um that if he feels there's anything
further he needs to add he willed him
thank you we now come to um statement
from secretary of state for health sadie
thank you madam deputy speaker
can i start by welcoming the honourable
member for ilford north to his new
position
and by also by the deputy speaker
wishing his predecessor the right
honourable member for leicester south
all the very best in his new role too
throughout this national effort i've
always been grateful for how this house
has worked together across the floor in
a constructive manner and i look forward
to that